[Musique]
lyon différentes techniques de karaté
le body karaté permet de se tonifier et
de s'assouplir
je suis donc accueilli aujourd'hui par
le club rambouillet sports karaté
on commence par une série
d'enchaînements assez facile au début où
tous les muscles sont sollicités aussi
bien mon bras que les jambes
j'écoute attentivement la professeur
véronique mesnil de vidéos multiple
championne de france de karaté sa
famille de venir que le cours a commenté
je suis un peu essoufflée normal ça va
puisque une fois qu'on a après les
chorégraphies qu'elles sont assez
répétitive et bien c'est moins dur j'ai
parlé trop vite les enchaînements
s'accélère il faut avoir un bon cardio
alors là ça se complique
les mouvements sont plus dur est en fait
plus on avance dans le court plus c'est
compliqué très bon jeu je m'étais faire
mieux dans ce court d'amateur il y à des
débutants mais aussi des personnes comme
siham qui fait du karaté depuis l'âge de
13 ans elle est venue découvrir ce
nouveau sport premier cours de body
karaté est ce que ça vous fait
le truc c'est à 98 ans
et puis de travail et cardio travail est
la cible à court terme et du coup il
nous reste peu de temps à rs combien de
temps de encore 10 15 minutes allaient
faire partie le cours de body karaté
s'est arrêté il y a dix ans se sont donc
grâce aux nombreuses demandes que ce
cours a rouvert pour la rentrée donc je
suis en présence de véronique minutes de
vidéo qui est que la professeure de body
karaté quils est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer déjà qu'est ce que le body
karaté alors le body karaté cédé au
rayonnement de karaté fait sur de la
musique
d'accord ça permet de travailler les
chaînes musculaires le cardio la
respiration tout ceci dans une bonne
ambiance ça permet de gérer son stress
et il y avait énormément talent qu'est
ce que c'est normal
oui ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que au
niveau de la fédération française de
karaté donc c'est la fédération qui a
mis en place le body karaté dans les
années 2000 il y à 90 % de femmes qui
pratiquent le body karaté dans notre
club on essaie d'inciter les hommes à
pratiquer le body karaté aussi et alors
pourquoi autant de femmes pourquoi cet
engouement alors je pense que comme
c'est un petit peu
un mélange de danse avec le tempo de la
musique on le pratique en individuel il
n'y a aucun coup il n'y a pas de
problème de technicité 1 on est moins
exigeant donc ça plaît beaucoup plus aux
femmes quatre hommes sur une petite
vingtaine de participants sont quand
même venus aujourd'hui et si vous aussi
vous voulez venir
digard à des rendez vous plus beaucoup à
20 heures au stade du moulin